- Hallo, Lisa!
- Hallo, Max, wie geht es dir?
- Super. Und dir?
- Auch gut, danke.
- Hi, Emma.
- Hallo, Max.
- Und du? Wer bist du?
- Ich bin Nico.
- Hallo, Nico. Du kommst nicht
aus Deutschland, oder?
- Entschuldigung?
- Ehm … Woher kommst du?
Ich bin Max und ich komme aus
Deutschland.
- Und ich bin Emma und ich komme
auch aus Deutschland.
- Ich bin Nico. Ich komme aus ehm ...
Spain?
- Spanien?
- Spanien, ja!
Ich komme aus Spanien.
- Und woher kommst du genau?
- Woher?
- Wo wohnst du in Spanien?
Wohnst du in Barcelona oder in Madrid?
- Sevilla!
- Du wohnst in Sevilla?
- Ich wohne in Sevilla.
- Nico war auch am Flughafen. Er hat
ein Problem: Seine Tasche ist weg.
- Oh. Und was machst du jetzt?
- Ich suche meine Tante.
- Nicos Tante wohnt hier in Deutschland.
Aber er hat die Adresse nicht.
- Kannst du deine Tante anrufen?
- Meine Tasche ist weg. Mein Telefon
ist weg. Und die Nummer ist weg.
- Und deine Familie? Kannst du deine
Familie anrufen?
- Nein.
- Kann dein Vater nicht helfen?
Er ist doch bei der Polizei.
- Gute Idee!
- Vater?
- Mein Vater ist Polizist. Police.
Vielleicht hilft er uns. Moment!